hello everyone and welcome back to one
of the greatest tournaments ever played
of course I'm talking about the 1959
candidates tournament that featured
eight players and half of those players
were either former or future world
champions as missile being the former
world champion and Petrosyan Italian
Fischer being the future world champion
so quite a strong tournament and the
other four of course were poor caressed
sweaters are really rich 3d Coulson and
the poll Benko so definitely definitely
a strong tournament and a very exciting
one every player played four games
against every other player so whoever
emerges victorious is definitely the
strongest now I already shown you one
game between Fisher and tall from this
tournament it's in one of my older
videos but I will put a link in the
description below if you want to check
it out it's also a very interesting game
this is another game from this
tournament I decided to show and many of
you know this many of you don't before
this tournament Fisher actually faced
adult two times and both of the games
were drawn but in this tournament it's a
different story but I'll get back to
that after I show you this game so
Fisher has the white pieces and he opens
with E for that's of course to be
expected c5 by Todd and I said that
Fisher said that Soviets were afraid to
face Fisher with the Sicilian in my
previous video but as you can see towel
really doesn't mind playing c5 against
Fisher Knight to f3 d6 and d4 so si
captures Knight captures Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and a sextile goes for the
knight or variation favor goes for
Bishop to c4 his standard move ecigs and
Bishop to b3 Bishop to e7 who had f4
doll castles and Queen to f3 now Queen
to c7 favored castles and b5 now and
here it's a very delicate delicate
position here I move like a three would
definitely favor white as it's not this
nasty b form of getting rid of the
knight on c3 but Fischer goes for the
early f5 interestingly he 5 is not is
not recommended here as even if
even if you play something like Bishop
to b7 going after the Queen and you do
decide to sacrifice the Queen would eat
captures on f6 after Bishop captures
pawn captures Queen captures and rook
captures it's still a better position
for black after b4 black will displays
this Knight and a white worm to really
have enough compensation it's a
different story in similar positions
when the bishop is on instead of b3 on e
2 and then when you sacrifice the Queen
you can capture with the bishop and then
the bishop automatically attacks attacks
the rook on a 8 so yeah I just wanted to
you know put that out there but in the
game Fischer played f5 and this was a
bit too early top plate b4 and now
Fischer played Knight to a4 and if he
decided to go for f5 immediately went up
wait before he should have gone for a
captures F captures on e6 with the idea
that after B captures now he has he
captures on f7 would check King to h8
and now Queen captures on c3 now if you
decide to capture the Queen would black
this doesn't really favor black after
Queen captures pawn captures you can't
grab material because if Knight captures
the bishop - thief d5 attacks the knight
and the rook
so after this Queen captures on c3 black
would play Queen to b7 and now white can
continue with Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen Knight captures pawn captures and
now if you now it's a playable position
if you play Queen captures now you get
Bishop to h6 and now it's extremely
dangerous and black has to be very
careful what it does of course you can't
capture because you get Knight to c6
with the check King has nowhere to go
the point is guarding g8 so you have to
block this and that there is nothing for
you to block this with you have to block
with the Queen and then simply Knight
captures and white wins the game
so after before and this might seem
reasonable since Fischer already played
at 5 but he decides to play Knight to a4
and now tile simply pushes a 5
he displaces this denied from d4 as well
so Knight to e2 and now if you look at
that position the position with this
knight on a 4 in this night and E -
isn't that great for white
to be seven mouthal will focus all of
his pieces to go for the e4 pawn Knight
to g3 and Knight B to d7
we have Bishop to e3 Bishop to c6 and
now Bishop to f2 Queen to d7 now
attacking d4 pawn sorry three times and
as Bishop moved his dark squared Bishop
to f2 now he makes room for the rook to
guard the e4 pawn from the e-file and
now tau plays d5 and this is one of
those moments in the life of us Cillian
player when you were able to put d5
without actually ruining your position
you feel great as you know if you push
d5 and you're playing the Sicilian
you're doing something great he captures
on d5 Knight captures on d5 and Knight
to e4 now and here at top plays Knight
to f4 and now this Knight is a monster
here fisher's knight on e4 is pinned
it's not gonna be easy to get rid of the
spin and you can't get rid of the knight
on g4 on f4 if you play g3 you lose the
game immediately do tonight to h3 check
King moves and now Knight to g5
attacking the Queen and now having a
triple attack on the knight on e4 you're
you're simply losing the piece and the
game Queen moves Knight captures it's
all over
so after this Knight to f4 move Fischer
tried c4 but now comes and even an even
greater idea here tau plays g6 with the
idea of playing G captures on f5
attacking the pink piece and winning the
game Fischer characters F captors and g6
and now comes the immediate f5 so no
tall doesn't waste time here Fischer
pushes g7 attacking tells rook we have
King characters and now Queen to g1
Queen to g3 check Fischer manages to
unpin the queen with check King to h8
and now Knight the c5 attacking tells
Queen and b7 we have Knight captures
Bishop captures Bishop captures Knight
captures attacking the Queen and now
Queen to c7 and this is now too much
there are simply too many threats Tallis
threatening Rock to g8 attacking the
Queen when the Queen moves rook captures
on g2 is coming also the g2 point is
already attacked twice by the night and
the bishop if that this bishop ever
moves there will be an open attack from
the Queen to the knight and seas and c5
so there are simply too many threats for
here - for white to handle official
place Queen to e3 and now comes Luke 88
defending the d5 pawn as d5 bonuses if
tile captured then Fischer could capture
the e5 pawn would check
so first all protects it and now there
is no way for Fischer to actually
protect the g2 pawn if you try something
like g3 you lose on the spot to do
tonight to h3 check King moves and now
comes f4 busting open the position this
rope is coming into play it's all over
so after rook 88 Fischer tried rook to
e2 he decided he has to give up some
material in order to survive top plays
of course Knight captures he doesn't
mind Queen captures and now Bishop
captures ng to completely shattering
Fischer's defenses and of course we said
that if Bishop if the bishop ever moves
there will be an attack open from the
Queen to the night
so first Fischer grabbed some material
Knight captures on a6 attacking tells
Queen Queen to e7 check and now Fischer
plays King captures on g2 and the now
comes the idea rook to g8 check and now
Fischer definitely has some problems if
he tries something like King to f3 then
after a four it's all over King has to
come to a four and now comes Queen to b6
and there is no defense against Queen to
h6 checkmate
if Fischer would try to prevent this by
playing something like Queen to h5 then
comes Queen to f2 and it's again
checkmate you only have one move to
block it and then Queen captures on f3 a
very nice checkmate so after this rock
to g8 check Fischer played King to h3
but now as you can see this rook is
completely cutting the king of the king
is only allowed to walk along the H file
and here is that it's actually a forced
checkmate in five moves so it's pretty
nice position for you to pause the video
and try to find it it's a pretty common
theme so you know you'll probably be
able to use it in your own games so I
will give it a couple of seconds if you
want to solve it
they're actually more more there's more
than one move that actually solves the
position in five moves so whichever you
find it's perfectly fine so for those of
you who were able to solve it
congratulations you're great player in
the game pal played Queen to g7 with the
idea of Queen to h6 checkmate but also
if you found something like rook to e6
with the idea of rook to h6 that also
works so top plate Queen to g7 here
Bishop to d1 was played to meet Queen to
h6 with Queen to h5 as the bishop is now
protecting the Queen but here tells them
to plate rook to e6 and in this position
Bobby Fischer resigned the game
what if you resign well there is no
defense against rook to h6 the King is
stuck on the H file you can block it but
that's like me you know there's really
no point to this so yeah after dr. he
said I'll resign the game and I did I
did say that I will tell you something
more about the results like I said
before this tournament Fischer and tall
played two games but both of them were
drawn but in this tournament in the 1959
candidates tall score against Fisheries
four to zero so that's that's very
uncomfortable for Bobby but okay later
on Bobby will settle the score and I
don't know the the information is
slightly different depending on where
you look for them but on the official
chess games.com database towels score
against Fischer throughout their entire
life is four wins the towel two wins for
Fischer and I believe five draws but
that's including only classical games if
you include a rapid and exhibition games
tender then their score is four when
style four wins Fischer and five draws
so we can say that after Fischer lost
these four games that he evened out the
score would tell so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said I
will put a link in the description to
the video I made like I think it was
like five months ago
also again between tal and Fisher from
this tournament it's also very enjoyable
if you want to check it out as usual you
can check to all my previous
videos here thankful for watching and I
will see you soon